verdicts coming back from the jury
inside bradford crown court and we can
tell you that savannah brockhill the
partner
of the mother of star hobson has been
found guilty of murder and guilty of
causing or allowing death of a child
the mother of star hobbs and the 16
month old baby
that died
has been found not guilty of murder but
guilty of causing or allowing death of a
child she's also been found not guilty
of manslaughter as well it's my
understanding that sentencing will
happen tomorrow but let me give you some
background
of this case a trial which has been
going on for eight weeks here at
bradford crown court savannah brockhill
the 28 year old her partner frankie
smith the mother of a 16 month old baby
a toddler star hobson they were charged
with causing and allowing her death and
murder star hobson died in september
last year just four months after her
first birthday forensics suggested that
it was
a catastrophic abdominal injuries orange
or injury that caused by blunt force and
trauma that caused her death now during
this eight week trial the court has
heard uh of large amounts of evidence
from family members from
medical experts from police officers and
a forensic pathologist which is said a
blow or blows
where likely a punch a kick or a stamp
delivered with a severe degree of force
caused the injuries which led to her
death in a matter of minutes the
prosecutors alleged that the toddler
suffered weeks of physical assault and
psychological harm before her death now
let's just talk you through a timeline
that we've got for you we can break down
the incidents leading up to star
hobson's death which also include a
number of referrals to social services
now star hobson as i mentioned died in
september last year from catastrophic
injuries it's another sad case where the
authorities appear to have failed to
intervene after concerns were raised it
was at the start of 2020 when friends
and family started become concerned for
star's well-being a friend of frankie
smith the mother
makes a first referral to social
services concerned with the care of star
police and social services then visited
frankie smith but the case was dropped
and then between january and september
multiple social services referrals were
made by family and friends of the family
as well it included one in may made by
star's great grandmother but it was
dismissed
as a malicious referral star's mother
then actually used that explanation in
future referrals to help close any
further
cases and then after another referral in
june police and social services arranged
for star to have a medical examination
for bruising smith blamed the bruising
on an accident involving a coffee table
doctors then concluded that there is
nothing unusual and the case again was
closed on the 4th of september then
social services visited unannounced
social workers saw serious bruising to
star's body but believe her mom's
account for what happened and then sadly
on the 22nd of september star died from
injuries that she received at her home
in keithley west yorkshire smith and
brock hill were both arrested two days
later on suspicion of murder and just to
reiterate
those verdicts again savannah brockhill
guilty of murder and guilty of causing
or allowing death of star hobson frankie
smith not guilty of murder and
manslaughter
but guilty of causing or allowing death
of a child